[Music]
before you see the movie about an evil
fictional technology company see the
story of Facebook a real-life evil
technology company the social network
experienced the world's smartest bill
about the world's dullest premise did
you answer affirmatively when Tyler and
Cameron Winklevoss and Divya Narendra
asked you to build harvardconnection
did you say yes in this dark
Shakespearean drama about the website
you're crazy and post minion means on
that uses snappy dialogue I deserve your
attention you have cognate my intention
you have the minimal amount select
directing and great performances to make
a story we're young millionaires sue
each other for more money feel really
high stakes
what was your ownership share diluted
down to point zero three person that's
still millions you greedy so god that's
not like any four point zero three
percent of Neopets journey to Harvard
where no one ever lets you forget it's
Harvard this is John Harvard were
gentlemen of Harvard Charles wanna Kevin
gospel Harvard Harvard Harvard Harvard
this is Harvard and meet Mark Zuckerberg
a star student with a mind of a
calculator the heart of a troll
Erica Albright's a bench and a wardrobe
of a comfy hobo he's determined to do
two things with his life make a world
respect him and make sure Jesse
Eisenberg gets every awkward know-it-all
nerd role in Hollywood take that Michael
Cera ha coasting off marks talent are a
succession of hot dudes in suits like
Eduardo the only Brazilian who doesn't
know how to party you see this is such a
good idea see maybe you shouldn't shake
it down we get into trouble you want to
end the party along I'm trying to pay
for the party Sean Parker the man on the
side who gets in the way of their
bromance and the wiggle by who briefly
got your hopes up at army hammer had an
identical twin or to put it another way
Lex Luthor dumped spider-man 4 in sync
and pisses off The Lone Ranger
if you want to know the real story
behind Facebook watch something else
because they're bending the truth harder
than the news your uncle post on his
wall in a film that makes up the
ex-girlfriend who supposedly inspired
the site makes up an obsession with
final clubs that tears marks friendships
apart tell me
Tom McKenney into Phoenix and makes him
into an awkward scowling robot we're in
real life he was a normal dorky college
kid within a couple of weeks tutors in
the school and signed up so and that's
when my roommates are like you know this
is pretty cool like whether this would
work at other schools but hey don't let
facts get in the way
I'm sure the real Shawn Parker loved
seeing himself as a paranoid coked out
cowardly maybe sort of statutory rapist
oh really son not my dad shot how old
are they so gather round for a film
that's not really about Facebook it's
about friendship that still nails what
it's like to use the website in this
masterpiece of crap that proves Aaron
Sorkin could make boring litigation
exciting you stole our whole goddamn
idea
David Fincher could make applying for an
internship look also welcome to Facebook
and Trent Reznor could make rolling down
a calm river field F age
[Music]
man I wish they'd make another Facebook
movie is a sentence I'd never thought
I'd say in this lifetime
starring Jesse Eisenberg as himself
Andrew Garfield the brazilian jiu Tim
from Jurassic Park the cloned Ranger a
single shade of gray he's thick enough
doc and all the laptops who gave their
lives so David Fincher could get the
perfect shot psych Club I know it's
realistic and everything but trying to
understand Sorkin dialog and a loud bar
is like your grandma trying to
understand how Facebook works no Nana
searchbar is not the same as the status
update call thanks for watching click
the boxes above for more honest trailers
and let us know what movie you'd like to
see get the honest treatment in the
comments below if you guys were the
inventors of Facebook you'd have
invented Facebook
yo Danny Fenton he was just 14 when his
parents got a strange machine I've got
to get back back to the past
Samurai Jack through who I of a nugget I
tuned in to honest trailers
week after week waiting for my comment
to be read out I just want my mother to
be proud of me